let's go next to uh preston
from birmingham now is this birmingham
alabama or united kingdom
preston from birmingham hi can you hear
me david yes i can it sounds like it's
alabama
not not uh uk yeah you can tell no
accent
that was the q i was immediately able to
deduce that
all right david well i took the time to
formalize my thoughts for this question
oh thank you
um i went ahead and wrote a thesis for
you that i'll submit for you to review
thank you so i have a few questions
regarding bernie sanders uh
raise the wage act sure um
so the raise the wage act would add to
25 to the federal minimum wage
every year through 2025 right um
after that the wage would be increased
by the annual percentage
increase of the median hourly wage of
all employees
yes um so my first question about this
is um why are they deciding to increase
the wage by the annual percentage
increase
of the median hourly wage as opposed
to something like adjusting for
inflation
um and also why are they um
specifically excluding uh annual
percentage increases in salaries from
that calculation
well i think that the the there's a
bunch of different stuff there first of
all
um when we talk about the hourly wage
you're talking about the wage for people
paid hourly
so it is logical to me that you wouldn't
index it
to salaried folks who might work 35
or 60 hours per week that part makes
sense so maybe we can take that piece
off the table i think
you would look at you would if you're
going to index an hourly wage you would
look at hourly workers is that fair
yes okay in terms of doing it to median
rather than inflation i don't know the
answer i've not i've not read about the
reason
the reason to do it median rather than
mean
uh seems obvious and as people have
given this example before if you put a
hundred people in a room and one of them
is bill gates
the mean wage will be really high but
the median
may not be uh because so so median
rather than mean makes sense but as far
as versus inflation i've seen a lot of
proposals that would index the minimum
wage to inflation i don't know why it's
being done
to the median hourly wage but i would be
interested in learning why
i would too um i completely agree with
everything you're saying though makes
sense
um i've got one more question for you
about this sure
um so sanders is proposing that 225
increase every year through 2025. um
what's your opinion on this time frame
of the rollout do you think it would be
faster
to or it would be better to increase
this wage faster
maybe as a way to benefit low wage
earners and allow them to put
money back into the local economy during
the pandemic
and on the other hand i understand that
small businesses would be hurt
by sudden wage increases as was
addressed in the town hall last night
yeah
um so what's your opinion on this time
frame do you think this is a realistic
goal do you think it should go faster
slower
so i would love for it to go faster but
i recognize that it's extraordinarily
unlikely to be politically viable and
when you look at senators like
kirsten cinema and joe manchin who
aren't even sure they
they want a 15 minimum wage the idea of
making it a 15
federal minimum wage tomorrow just seems
so unlikely so i'm not surprised that
they're looking at phasing it in over
time now of course
by 2025 a 15
minimum wage is going to be a lot less
than it would be today
because of inflation not a lot less i
mean the u.s has relatively low
inflation but
it's already going to be time to look at
the the next step
at that point in time but i'm not
surprised because
um particularly in places where the
state minimum
a lot of states already have minimum
wages of 10 11 12 14 even
in places where they the state minimum
wage really is
in still in the sevens you're talking
about more than doubling it
and whatever you believe the minimum
wage ultimately should be
and i believe it should be much higher
doubling the minimum wage
will have an economic impact and so i'm
not surprised at all that it would be
phased in over time and
uh if bernie is behind it i think that
he's he's thought it out well
yeah i agree david thank you for the
time uh taking time to answer my
questions hope you have a good day
you too all right very good great to
hear from from our friends
in alabama as always